[Music]
mike is in rock hill south carolina hey
mike welcome to the dave ramsey show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i feel like we have hit a sort of a
brick wall
we are trying to build a house
and are having no luck without a credit
score so far
okay i've talked to some folks at
churchill
and according to them they go through
local lenders for a construction loan
yeah and every local lender has requires
a credit score to get started
even though we have at least 20 down if
not way more than that
okay and i just don't know have you
tried a credit union
i have i've worked with my credit union
i've been with since i was born
and they do manual underwriting but they
tell me they have to have a credit score
to get started bull
and then they go from there i'm
challenging that
they don't have to because they're
portfolioing that loan they're not
selling that loan to anyone
that's just an underling you need to get
to a manager a senior
the president of the credit union
depending on how what size the credit
union is
they do not need a credit score to make
a construction loan that's absolutely
asinine
i don't believe it okay i would bust up
on some people now
you know bank of america is not going to
make you a construction loan without a
credit score i don't have any doubt but
i'm not doing business with those
doofuses anyway
so but your local bank i mean we're
listen here's the thing if you're
dealing with a mortgage like a fannie
mae mortgage
you can get that manually underwritten
but most of the mortgage companies
don't know how to do it because fannie
mae requires a credit score
to package them together or properly
done manual underwriting which not many
people other than church you'll know how
to do
okay so that you will run into problems
there
and there's a valid reason for that
because they're packaging those loans
together they don't keep those loans
they sell them
and in order to sell them they've got to
be packaged a certain way does that make
sense
yes and if the opposite of selling them
in this business is called portfolioing
the loan meaning the bank
keeps the loan in house the credit union
is portfolioing this construction loan
or the local bank is either one
and so they can they can make up
whatever rules they want to make up
there is absolutely no pressure on them
from an outside force of any kind
that's requiring a credit score and so
it's just a dumb butt
policy that you got to bust up into
meaning you got to get somebody use a
brain i've been with you my whole
freaking life since i was
born and i got 20 down and i've got the
permanent mortgage set up
to take you take out the construction
loan you're only going to have the loan
on the books while the house is being
built when it's completed the mortgage
is sitting over here already
pre-approved
the takeout letter is in my hand to take
out the construction loan
and so this is almost a no risk for you
you know me you know my
income you know my net worth and my
other stuff or i can show it all to you
and so the credit score is a completely
bogus non-related
issue you follow me yes
so that's how i'm talking to the
president of the credit union or the
manager of whatever or i don't know how
big a credit union this is but
a lot of credit unions that are small
enough that the president so you're
gonna end up talking to which is fine
and it's you know it's just asinine and
so this is one of those things you just
challenge the policy
and you just say no it's not okay it's
not okay that you're treating me a
customer that way
as if i somehow didn't pay my bills and
and
they do not if they're portfolioing the
loan
if a bank is keeping the loan in-house
the bank can completely make up
whatever rules it wants to make up or
waive
any rules it wants to waive because
they're keeping the loan it's just like
if i'm loaning you money i can make up
whatever rules i want to make up
and if i go well you don't have a credit
score but you've got all this other
stuff well
i don't need a credit score it's okay
you know and that's all we're talking
about here
so uh but yeah you run into people
who've forgotten how to think
and sometimes we have to remind them
well that's the hard thing it's just
challenging the industry right and so
when you don't
have a credit score because you've
gotten yourself out of debts and
it's been a long enough time that it's
not there there are going to be things
insurance renting an apartment
underwriting a mortgage construction
loan all those things
uh you can run up against things because
the industry has been so
set but there are ways around it all yep
i mean anthony sat the other day he's
got it on youtube
and called 15 apartment complexes and
just
asked the question he said i'm moving
from out of town uh i'm just getting
started moving on my parents house
i don't have a credit score can i will
you rent to me and out of 15 12 said
they would
yeah there you go with a deposit um with
them you know
and you said is it a couple of them had
an extra deposit if you didn't have
credit scores yeah
and a couple of them were just no it's
no problem there's no problem at all
if you got your deposit and you got you
know they have to have proof of income
you have to have a job
yes yes but uh uh you know normal stuff
that the apartment's going to look at
but this idea that no apartments were
rented without a credit score he got a
12 out of 15 that would and he didn't
say i'm anthony o'neil he just called
and said
hey i'm just checking i'm coming out i'm
moving from out of town and you just
and he put it all on youtube so you can
pull it up on the ao's channel and see
that somebody says oh you have to have a
credit score if you're in the room
apartment no you don't
oh you know 12 out of 15. dentists agree
apartment complexes agree 12 out of 13
apartment complexes agree